- My name is Vaughn and I am alive.
- My name is Essence and I am alive.
- My name is Vicky and I'm alive.
Should I say that more lively?
- My name is Augusta.
- And I am alive.
- I'm alive, yes.
Yep, I'm alive.
- I am most certainly alive.
- Why am I here?
(slow music)
(woman moans)
(laughing)
- Where was I when I found out
Blake Shelton was The Sexiest Man Alive?
- I was on the New Jersey Transit.
- I was sitting in a chair.
A nice chair, just relaxing in a chair.
- Yeah, who gives a shit?
- Is he really?
(laughs) Like, dead ass, I'm not kidding.
Is Blake Shelton really
The Sexiest Man Alive?
- To say I was outraged
would be an understatement.
- Go, Blake, this is your
time, this your moment.
- When I first heard about it,
I thought people were saying
he was the most sexist man alive.
And I was like, "Damn,
fucked up, but Hollywood."
And then, I read that it was
the most sexiest man alive.
And I was shook.
- At first I was like, "How did this guy
"get voted the most sexiest man alive?"
And then, I was like,
"Hey, if he can do it,
"maybe 2018 is my year."
- I see where the
committee was coming from.
Actually, no, I don't really see
where (chuckles) the
committee was coming from,
to be honest with you.
Is he really?
- I feel like, honestly,
people named Blake
have been getting called sexy
too much across all of history.
- Why is this a video?
- I just feel like for so long,
Blake has been kind of this
underdog within country.
Perhaps not underdog
in terms of popularity.
But in terms of sex appeal.
- So out of like all of the men,
Blake Shelton is The Sexiest Man Alive?
- Like, what about Pharrell?
- I mean, a Hemsworth or something.
- Jake Gyllenhaal.
- Mahershala Ali.
- That guy from Moonlight.
- [Vaughn] Honestly, any one
of the five in One Direction.
- [Essence] Idris Elba, Lance Gross.
- [Vicky] Justin Theroux.
- [Vaughn] The Ryans,
Ryan Gosling, Ryan Reynolds.
- [Essence] Ryan Gosling.
- [Vaughn] Billy Ray Cyrus
over Blake Shelton, I think (chuckles).
Jeff Goldbloom.
- [Augusta] My mailman, Ralph.
- [Vaughn] A firefighter.
- Why do we care?
- I am alive and I was not a part
of this decision making process at all.
No one consulted me, I
didn't get a phone call.
I didn't get an email.
- Who makes those lists?
- This has white male written all over it.
- Gotta be Russia.
- Wait, people are upset about this?
I feel like we have a few more things
to be upset about these days.
- Here's what sexy is.
What you find sexy right here.
And that's some really
nice pecks are very sexy.
And also, your heart, I guess.
But the actual heart isn't actually sexy.
If you've ever seen a
heart, it's gross, man.
- Congratulations, Blake.
I know you really didn't do anything
for this besides exist but--
- Good job.
- I guess, as they say, "Chew tobacco,
"chew tobacco,
"chew tobacco, spit."
- And as Jake Paul says,
"Dab on them haters."
(operatic music)
(sign squeaks)